[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم وحلقه جديده من
حلقات افكار الاستاذ استاذنا الدكتور جودي
عبد الخالق الحقيقه انا كنت مخطط ان
الحلقه تبقى لموضوعات اخرى جديده ولكن كم
كبير جدا من الاسئله
جاءتني سواء من متخصصين او من غير متخصصين
مهتمين بالشان المصري ومن مصر او من
خارجها بيسالوا على فكرتين طرحهم الدكتور
جوده في حلقات سابقه الفكره الاولى
معارضته للتعويم والفكره الثانيه تحفظاته
على فكره التوريق فقررنا انه الدكتور جوده
يتكرم علينا بمزيد من الايضاحات من خلال
اجابه هذه الاسئله مساء الخير معال
الدكتور مساء
الحريه لكم وللمشاهدة
في التجارب الاقتصاديه لا يناسب مصر
وانتهز وجود حضرتك علشان اتاكد ان انا
فاهم ان حضتك بتقول التعويم له شروط هذه
الشروط عشان تكون مفيده لا تنطبق على
الاقتصاد المصري والاقتصادات
المماثله لانه التعويم هيكون في الحاله
المصريه معناها خفض لقيمه العمله حين يتم
قيمه خفض العمله لن نستفيد منها لانه احنا
ما عندناش القدره على ان احنا نزود
صادراتنا لان الجها جهاز الانتاجي عندنا
محدود وما عندناش قدره ان احنا نستغني عن
كثير مما نستورده رغم غلو سعرها بسبب
التخفيض لان هي احتياجات اساسيه لا يمكن
ان نستغني عنها ولا ننتجها ده واحد اثنين
الاضرار بالغه وكبيره لانه ده هدي الى
ارتفاع
الاسعار سواء كانت محليه او يعني مستورده
وهيدي الى مزيد من الفقر كل هذا مفهوم
مبوط لكن السؤال اللي بيساله الناس ايوه
هو الان نحن امام وضع مختل الان اذا لم
نخفض قيمتها او لم نعوم بالمعنى ده يعني
تخفيض العمله هيبقى عندنا دايما اوجه
الخلل اللي الناس كلها عارفاها ان اموال
العاملين في الخارج مثلا لا تاتي الى
الجهاز المصرفي ان في سوق سودا المستثمر
لا يرغب ان ياتي لان في سعرين ف كيف ترد
على ذلك مع على دكتور انا
بقول يعني وده ردا على كل من يدعون ان
هناك حتميه انه التعويم حتمي التعويم لايس
حت مين على الاطلاق دي نمره واحد ليه
بمعنى ان هناك بدائل وهتكلم في البدائل بس
نمره اثنين انه اذا عبنا ولم نفعل شيئا
اخر قد نضر بالوضع الاقتصادي في المجمل من
ان
ا لا نعوم على الاطلاق عظيم دي نقطه انيه
النقطه لاثه ان لازم ادرك ان هناك تبعات
غير
اقتصاديه للتعويم وما يترتب عليه ويبقى
عندنا تصور لكيفيه التعامل مع هذه التبعات
انا اقصد بالتحديد لانه خلي بالك التعويم
ممكن لو نظرت لو كتبنا كده المعادله
الخاصه بالتويم رياضيا
واعدنا تبديل الحدود والكلام ده انا اكتشف
انه التعويم بيعني بمعنى تخفيض قيمه
العمله طبعا معناه تخفيض حصه الاجور في
الناتج المحلي الاجبال انا بالنسبه لي
كساري ده موضوع مهم جدا ماقدرش اتجاهله
على الاطلاق تخفيض القيمه اللي بياخذها
العا حصه الاجور حصه الاجور معنى اذا كان
الناتج المحل الاجمالي بنقسمه بين متلقي
الاجور يعني من يعرقون ويكدح ويتلقون
اجرا سواء عملهم ده لحساب الغير او
لحسابهم وبين من يعيشون العائد الملكيه هم
مثلا اصحاب الاراضي اصحاب اصحاب الاراضي
اصحاب راس المال كل من يحققون الارباح اه
ها فمعروف كده اف ب الموضوع انتز المناسبه
وذكر انه مباشره ايه لما تخفض لازم تعرف
ان ده معناه انت بتخفض حصه الاجور ومعناها
عمليه اعاده توزيع الدخل ازاي بخفض حصه
الاجور انا كان اجري 1000 اه تم تغيير
قيمه العمله انخفضت العمله انا باخ خد
1000 بس ال000 بقت قدرتها الشرائيه اقل
مظبوط ده اللي تقصده حضرتك ا ده المقصود
مفهوم طبعا انما النقطه مش واضحه للي بيبص
الايه للموضوع انك انت اوكي بتغير السعر
بتاع العمله في مواجهه العملات الاخرى
انما في النهايه في النهايه احد التتابعات
لهذا التعديل اذا كنا نتحدث عن تخفيض قيمه
العمله هو انقاص حصه العمل من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي فاذا كان ده مطلوب لانه
حصه العمل المبالغ فيها يبقى ده تطور
ايجابي تضبط الايقاع ازاي في سوق النادي
الاجنبي بحيث تقضي على هذا الخلق بين
السعر الرسمي وما عدام الاسعار انا اقوللك
بقى مساله بسيطه جدا انت يعني بالتعبير
الاقتصادي لديك هذا الخلل ان عندك فائد
طلب فائض طلب على الدولار فائد طلب في
المجمل على مستوى الاقتصاد ككل ويترجم
بفائض طلب على على الناد الاجنبي يعني
بستو ود كتير مظبوط اه طيب تمام لان هو في
القصاد بنتكلم عن فاجوت فجوه فرق يعني لو
خدنا الناتج المحل الاجمالي بيعتبره
الاساس هذا الناتج جزء منه بيوجه
الاستهلاك والجزء بيوجه للادخار
وللتصدير
اوكي طيب لو ان معدل الخارك ضعيف كما هو
الشان
عندنا يبقى معنى كده انه ده في حد ذاته
سبب اللي عن فجوه لانه هيبقى في خلل بين
الطلب وبين العرض نتيجه
لارتفاع معدل الاستهلاك في الم انت عندك
في يعني الارقام متضاربه جدا انا بشوف
تيجي في التصريحات بقوللك معدل الادخار
عندنا 6% 7% انا هقول تجاوزا 10% ويبقى
الاستهلاك كام
90% الفجوه دي بتترجم مباشره في فوه في
مجال التبادل التجاري فيبقى
عندك عجز في ميزان التبادل التجاري معيه
مع الخارج خلاص هو ده لب
المشكله طيب اذا كنا مش هنعوم لان ده رايي
ومصر عليه طب نعمل ايه هوؤ السؤال وج جدا
هو ده السؤال ايوه مظبوط وعن حق لابد ان
يثار اللي ترجع لورا شويه خطوتين لاثه
اربعه وتتعامل مع لب الموضوع الا هو فجوه
الطلب طب عامها ازاي بقى يعني في المدى
القريب جدا وفي المدى المتوسط في المدى
الطويل اجراءات تختلف في المدى القريب جدا
نعمل ايه اقول لك تعمل ايه انت عندك فائد
يعني الوردات بتاعتك حاليا حوالي 70 مليار
دولار ما ما
يعادل يعني بتصدر باليوان
وب 70 مليار اه الواردات اه وصدرتك حاليا
في حدود نص هذه القيمه نقول 30 مليار 30
مليار خلاص اه انا طبعا اتمنى ان
انا التخفيض يساعدني في ان انا اعلي قيمه
الصادرات لكن احنا قلنا الايه الشروط ان
ده صعب ان احنا نزود الصادرات بقدر كبير
اللي اقدر اعمله في في المدى الحالق الدات
نقلل الوردات الوردات
ازاي منطق صندوق النقد الدولي والبنك
الدولي وال هيئه المعونه الامريكيه ووزاره
الخزانه وكل الاسياد دول بيقول لك لابد ان
يتم ذلك من خلال السوق يا عم ازاي قال لك
من خلال تغيير سعر الصرف فلما تغير ورداتك
تبقى اعلى جنيه لكن احنا قلنا ده ل مشاكل
كتير جدا طب بتعملها ازاي نرجع للكتاب
بتاع منظمه التجاره العالميه اللي مصر عضو
فيها كتاب اللي هو اسمه الجات الجات اتفاق
الجات
1994 انا واثق ان كتير من اللي بيسمعونا
عارفينه واللي ما يعرفش بيرجع يشوف ايه
الحكايه ده هو الدستور اللي بيحكم علاقات
الدول في مجال التبادل الدولي والمنظمه هي
الجهه القوامه على التزام الجميع بتنفيذ
مبادئ هذا الدستور لما نقرا هذا الكتاب
جيدا و ثقه كبيره جدا يعني فوق ال 500
صفحه في النص الاصلي بالاضافه الى احالات
و بيقول الاتي الماده 18 ب تحديدا الماده
18 ب
من اتفاق الجات
1994 بيقول ان البلد العضو ومصر بلد عضو
فيق مصر بلد مؤسس لمنظم التجاره من سنه
95 اذا تعرض اقتصادها لضغوط تشكل خطوره
على الوضع العام سواء وضع العام اقتصاديا
او سياسيا او اجتماعيا او الى اخره فيمكنه
اتخاذ تدابير بالمخالفه للمبادئ العامه
لهذا
الاتفاق تصل الى حد حظر الواردات من بنود
معينه او وضع سقف لما يستورد من سلع معينه
في شكل حصص او حظر مؤقت
او فرض ضرائب جمركيه عاليه برض بالمخالفه
ده الموضوع وبالتالي كل المطلوب انك انت
حاليا يجي نطبع على مصر ب في حاله دي
مصر بتتعرض لضغوط شديده من الاتجاهات
الاستراتيجيه الاربعه من الجنوب بدا من
اثيوبيا وباب المندب لغايه السودان صح كده
ومن الغرب كلنا عارفين القوى الكبرى اللي
هما يعني تداعت الاكله على الاسع زي ما
بيقولوا في ليبيا ايوه طبعا بتشوف اللعيبه
اللي في ليبيا مظبوط وطبعا فيم الشق ايو
في في غزه يعني الموضوع واضح جدا والبحر
الاحمر الجهه الشرقيه ملتهبه مظبوط طيب ده
معناه ايه معناه انه نمره واحد عائدات
المرور في قناه السويس اللي هو احد مصادر
الريع الاستراتيجي بتاعنا تراجعت بشده
تراجعت بشده مظبوط طبعا في ظرف اسابيع
يعني مش طيب دي بنسميها صدمه خارجيه صدمه
خارجيه دي واحده من الصدمات الخارجيه
مزبوط واحده من الصدمات الخارجيه كمثال
يعني وبعدين الوضع في غازه
خلق عليك التزامات طبعا مش كده ولا ايه
طبعا التزامات دي يعني معناها مزيد من
الضغوط
كص وايد مجال الحركه بتاعك العزبان مفهومه
جدا وبالتالي في المجمل ده جزء من الصدمه
الخارجيه اللي تعرض لها اقتصادك والازمه
في السودان خلقت عليك صدمه ب تدفقات
المهاجرين الاف من المهاجر تع دلوقتي معصر
ف طبقا لبعض يقوللك تس مليون 10 مليون
يعني معناها من كل 100 واحد عايشين في مصر
منهم واحد ابتا 10 ضيوف اهلا بهم
و90 مش كده ولا ايه دي تكلفه عاليه جدا
وبالتالي لو انا عملت ملف للموضوع واقول
له بص بقى هذه جوانب الصدمات الخارجيه
اللي تعرضت لها
مصر في في السنوا الاخير السنوات الاخيره
ودي التكلفه بتاعتها وان انا في هذه حاله
لازم اتخذ
تدابير خارج المنطق الاساسي بتاع منظمه
التجاره ان انا هفرض قيود على ال فلو نرجع
بقى لموضوع وده قلته انا في سنه 16 16 قلت
له انت هتعمل كل القلبان ده عشان تاخد 12
مليار دولار من صندوق النقد الدولي في ذلك
الحين كان قيمه واردات مصر 60 مليار جنيه
دولار قلت لو انت خفضت ورداتك بنسبه الخمس
يعني
20% استنادا ل حقوقك طبقا للماده 18 ب في
اتفاقيه الجد 94 هو ممكن خمس 60 كام هيبقى
حوالي 12 يعني 12 مش كده ولا ايه على طول
كده 12 مليار وبالتالي تستطيع تجنب هزه
عنيفه لاشياء كثيره في الاقتصاد من خلال
التعويم طب انا هستاذن حضرتك يعني اتاكد
ان انا فهمت انا واصدقائي يعني انا لم
اكمل اجابه والاستفسار هنا ممكن كويس كده
مش ده الاجراء الوحيد مش ده الاجراء
الوحيد الاجراء الثاني ان ما انا عاوز
اوضح الاجراء الاولاني وارجع لاجراء انضح
ونكمل طيب احنا كده بنتكلم على الاجراء
الاولاني الاول احنا حتى تكون الصوره
واضحه والتسلسل واضح الاجراء الاولاني
اللي الدكتور جوده بيقترح بديلا عن
التعويم هو الحد من الواردات صح والحد من
الواردات ده هدفه الاقتصادي انه انا هو
ليه في ازمه دولار وفي سوقين لان الطلب
على الواردات كثير جدا المعروض من الدولار
لان احنا لا نصدر كثيرا محدود فهيبقى في
ضغط على الدولار الدوله مش قادره تلبيه
فالسوق السودا بتلبيه فبقى فيه الخلل فاذا
انخفض الطلب اذا قلت الواردات هقل الطلب
على الدولار هيكون ما فيش سوق سوده لانه
مش هتبقى المشكله موجوده دي منطق ده
المنطق الاقتصادي الاليه انه حضرتك بتقول
اللجوء الى منظمه التجاره العالميه لانه
وفقا لميثاق اللي هي اتفاقيه الجاد 18 ب
18 ب بتقول اذا كان في دوله تعرضت الى
صدمات وحضرتك اوضحت ان مصر تعرضت الى
صدمات او اي دوله اخرى تستطيع ان تستجير
بهذه الماده في ان هي تفرد قيود تفرد حصص
تمتنع عن الواردات وللتوضيح لان انا جالي
اسئله ثانيه بيقول هو حد منعكم ما تعمله
فيمكن مش عارفين انه لو انا مثلا امتنعت
عن استيراد سلعه من من الهند او من
اندونيسيا تقول لي بالمثل لن استورد منك
لكن الاستعانه بهذه الماده
معناها ان هم ما يعملوش كده بالمثل معي
لان انا متضرر هم مش متضررين طبعا لا شروط
انهك انت يعني في اليه داخل منظمه التجاره
العالميه انك انت بترجع بقى تتشاور مع
شركائك التجاريين كويس كده اتالي وبيبقى
في استعداد للتفاهم لانه احنا مش عايزين
نغرق المركب اللي احنا رابين فيه احنا
الاثنين اتفاهم مع الصين اتفاهم مع الهند
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي بس دي كانت نقطه مهمه
هي واضحه جدا في زان حضرتك بحيث ان هي
تبدو بديهيه لكن للاخرين انه اذا لم نلجا
الدكتور يقصد نلجا لدي لانه حتى لا
تعاقبنا الدول انا همنع او اقلل ورداتي
منهم هم كمان هيقلل وارداتهم منا يبقى لكن
اللجوء الى منظمه التجاره يعني يعفينا من
ذلك هي البند الاول او الاجراء الاول
للاستغناء عن التعويم الاجراء الثاني
الاجراء الثاني ان انت لابد ان تتخذ
تدابير لتخفيض الطلب الكلي في المجمل
بمعنى انه حتى ما لا يتم استيراده من
الخارج تلاز تخفض الانفاق
ا
داخليا بحيث انك ترفع معدل الادخار عن هذه
النسب المترديه جدا لان انت بنسبه 6 7%
اذا كنت عايز معدل نمو
6% كما هو مستهدف تمام فمعناه انك لابد
تستثمر 18% او 20% من الناتج المحلي
اجمالي اذا كان دد خارك في حدود 10% وانت
عايز تستورد او
تستثمر 20% يبقى مع عندك 10% من الناتج في
شكل عجز لابد ان يسوى اما بالاستثمارات
المباشره او بالاقتراض فاذا حضرك بتقتل ان
الحكومه تقلل لا لابد تقلل انفاقها بحيث
ان هي لا تضطر للاقتراض ويبقى عندنا فقض
نقدر نستثمره صحيح واذا استثمرنا يقل
الواردات صح كده مظبوط مبوط طيب اتفضل هنا
بقى دي معناها انه مباشره لما اجي اتخذ
اجراءات لتخفيض الطلب الكلي غير الوردات
بقى الطلب الوردات طلب على منتجات الغير
اه لما الطالب الكل في المجمل هنا لازم
اتوقف عند موضوع العجز المالي او العجز في
الموازنه العامه
للدوله بمعنى ان العجز في الموازن العامه
للدوله حاليا وصل الى حدود حرجه جدا
منسوبا الى الناتج احنا دائما بنتكلم مش
العجز في المطلق انما العجز منسوبا الى
الناتج المحلي الايه
الاجمالي القاعده تقريبا يعني مثلا بتاخد
اتفاقيه ماسترخت بتقول انه الحدود
الطبيعيه للعجز بين الدول في الدول
الاعضاء لا يجوز ان يتحد يتخطى 3% من
الناتج حك بتتكلم عن عجز الموازنه العامه
ايوه ك يعني الفرق ما بين الواردات
اوف الفر الايرادات والمصروفات بالنسبه
للا للحكومه بكل مستوياتها فاذا كان اذا
قلنا القاعده اللي هي او حد الامان للعجز
المالي انجاز
التعبير قياس على موضوع ماسترخت 3% من
الناتج فانت تجاوزت الموضوع ده دلوقتي
اعتقد انه الم يمكن يقرب 7 88% تجاوز
السبعه طبعا اوكي يبقى دي اول اول واجب ان
انا لازم اوقف وقفه صارمه مع معنى الكلام
بالبلدي ان انا ما
مدش رجليا خارج اللحاف بتاعي عظيم
واتكلمنا وانا كنت وزير طبعا وعارف
كوزير وبضمير مستريح اقدر اقوللك واقول
للساده المشاهدين ان ممكن تخفض
الانفاق من مجالات مختلفه انفاق الحكومه
بنسبه
الخمس ولا ولا يحدث مشاكل في الخدمات اللي
بتقدمها الحكومه ل ولا في المشرات ولا في
الكلام ده
كله انما ده بذخ في غير محل وطيني مثل بذخ
يمكن توفيره مع الدكتور هقوللك مثلا انت
حاليا في الظرف الراهن لو تيجي
تشوف المظاهر الاحتفاليه بتاع الحكومه في
مناسبات
مختلفه ده انفاق
انفجري مثلا
بمناسبه انتخاب الرئيس ف في هوجه من الايه
التهاني وصط كبار المسؤولين اه اهو مش
بيهني من جيبه ده من جيب انا وجيبك وجيب
اللي بيسمعونا اه يعني اللي فطات اللي في
الشوارع والجرايد ولا طبعا طبعا دي واحد
ناهيك عن يعني مضمون الكلام الكلام ده
بالنسبه للفساد لكن سيب دي على جب بتكلم
لو الناس مستقيمه وفلا ده موضوع الموضوع
الثاني سفر المسؤولين للخارج انا بتابع
الموضوع اشوف مثلا ثلاثه وزراء راحين
واشنطن بمناسبه اجتماعات الربيعه والخريف
والكلام دوت والمده قد تتجاوز يخلص
الاجتماعات وقال لك لا ده قاعد بقى بيعمل
لقاءات مع مش
عارف اسمها بيسموها ايه جماعات الراي و
مؤسسات الفكر والكلام ده كله او انه وزير
راي عشان يقابل رئيس الشركه ده كلام
الوزير رايح واخد طياره بيدفع فلوس ب ببات
في فندق بيسرب مصاريف كل ده من المال
العام المال العام وانت عندك حكومه كبيره
فوق ال 30 وزير صحيح ده نمره اثنين كوس
كده
ا نمره لاثه انت حاليا ال الجهاز المصرفي
عندك بيحظ الناس حضا الانفاق على الانفاق
صح كل يوم مش كده ولا ايه انا طبعا
مطاردات ماش اقوللك يوميه يا جدعه انا
عندي كارت واحد شايله للزمن لكن انا لو
مش كري ايوه بطاقه ائتمان للزمن للمناسبات
انما يعني ومبدئي في الحياه انا لا يمكن
اروح استلف عشان اصرف اطلاقا
فايه الموضوع انما انت عملت ثقافه مجتمعيه
صح ال حد ناس تروح تصيف مش كده ولا ايه
بالقرض بالقرض تروح تعمل حج وعمره ايضا
بالقرض ده صحيح انا مش ضد الكلام ده دي
انشطه مشروعه واحيانا تكون ضروريه ولكن
بمنطق لانه في النهايه لما تيجي تشوف وداع
المصرين اللي هي الادخار العائلي جزء من
الادخار العائلي اللي الحكومه بتشفط في
عجز الجزء الاني بيروح فين بقى البنوك
تسلف للاستهلاك
في النهايه ده بيسمع فين بقى في العجز
العجز وفي علاقتك مع الخارج اه تمام ف انا
عايز اقول انت عندك ده انا ما عنديش ما
يكفي من الاموال حتى استثمرها ايوه علشان
اقدر احقق نسبه النمو المطلوبه اللي
تخليني اعيش كويس اللي تغطي ا يعني
الزياده في عدد المواليد وتفيض فبضطر ان
انا اقترض او ان انا احاول اقنع المستثمر
يجيل لي والمستثمر ما بيجيش بالضبط كده
عايز اقول انه بمناسبه الديون والكلام ده
اللي هي الورطه اللي احنا فيها حاليا عايز
انبه لنقطه مهمه جدا لا يتصورن احد ممن
يشاهدنا وانا مسؤول عن الكلام دوت ان لو
انا ديون مصل الخارجيه حاليا في حدود 165
مليار تقريبا دولار ما
يعادل انه كل دي نتجت عن اوضاع ضروريه جدا
والتزامات لابد من مواجهتها غير صحيح
الكلام ده قد لا يعلم الجميع انه مصر
حاليا في علاقتها مع الخارج في مجال
الاقتراب الموضوع محتاج الى عاده نظر
شديده جدا لانه اولا في ضغوط بوسائل شته
على مصر
للاقتراب اما ترغيبا او ترهيبا وعايز اوقف
العمليه دي بالتالي بقى في يعني عندك
سياسه الاقترا وبعدين لما تقرب تشوف اخر
تقرير طلعته وزاره التعاون الدولي بيقول
ان في استراك بتاع ده وثيقه شراكه
استراتيجيه بين مصر والبنك الدولي ووثيقه
سياسه استراتيجيه بين مصر والاتحاد
الاوروبي وسياسه وثيقه استراتيجيه بين مصر
والولايات المتحده واتصور انه بلاد زي
اليابان والصين لها نفس الحكايه هذه
الوثائق وانا حضرت المناقشات بتاع بعضها
من غير ما افص عشان ما ودش اطراف تانيه في
الموضوع لا تخضع بالاهتمام الكافي من
جانبنا وبالتالي الطرف الثاني بيحط اللي
هو عايزه فت اذا بتخر عشان تخدم اهداف
غيرك بتختر ل خدمه اهدافك دي مساله مفهومه
لما تقترض عشان تهدم غير مساله خطيره
بتشير الى المفروض ان في وثيقه قوميه
بتقول الفئه 20 30 مش كده برض دي وثيقه
بتحدد اولويات مصر اتفقت اختلفت معاها بس
المفروض ان دي وثيقه بتعبر عن احتياجات
مصرص الوثائق الاخرى بتبدد زي ما حضرتك
اشرت في شرك كء التنميه بياتو يقترحوا
عليك وانت حضرتك بتقول انه الحكومات
المصريه بتقبل هذه الوثائق بدون اهتمام
كبير وقد تجرفها او تحرف هذه الوثائق عن
اولوياتها
فاقترعوا
علشان اعمل مشروع ليس من اولوياتي مبوط طب
انا مثال اخير قبل ما نتجوز حضرتك قلت انه
لابد من خفض الانفاق وقلت الانفاق ده
بياخد اشكال كتيره الحكومه تنفق او و
السفر الزائد التهاني الىى اخره واشرت الى
ان في مشروعات زي ما انا فهمت حضرتك انه
اقترنا من اجلها وهي ليست ضروريه اديني
مثل او اثنين اديلك
مثل انت لما تيجي مثلا تاخد موضوع زي
القطار السريع اه كده لو نظت لله في
اطار اطار السراع ده بيصل منين لفين في
بيقوللك من السخنه
لغايه في اثنين هم واحد من السخنه لغايه
سيدي كرير اظن ولا العالمين اه سخنه
العالمين اه التاني بقى يقوللك هياخد فين
من نقطه ما على ساحل البحر المتوسط لغايه
ما تنزل موازي ل سكه الحديد بتاع الصعيد
يعني بطول النيل يعني بطول النيل سؤال هل
انت عندك مراكز انتاجيه عشان هيخدم مين
الكلام دوت الخطين يعني الخطين وعلى فرض
انه عندي مراكز انتاج في الجزء الاولاني
اللي هو من السخنه ممكن انا افهم من
السخنه يبقى معناها بالمعيار الاستراتيجي
وانا افهمه جدا واقدره ان ده ظهير لقناه
السويس حصل مشكل في قناه السويس اقدر امش
تنق برا مظبوط ماشي ده مفهوم انما الموضوع
مش بهذا الشكل فانت ق تتوسع هنا وتتوسع
هنا وتتوسع هناك في في الغرب دي مشروعات
انا
شايف منطلق فقه الاولويات مش وقتها مش
وقتها على
الاطلاق انا مش هتكلم بقى على الحاجات
اللي تمت دلوقتي ولازم تتعامل معه باعتبار
تمت حاول تعظم العائد او المردود زي ايه
ما هي دي يعني مثلا زي ايه مشروعات تمت و
كنت شايف ان حجه جدوها محد العاصمه
الاداريه الجديده اه على سبيل المث كم
تكلفت معال الدكتوره والله انا ماعرفش
السبب ورغم اني حاولت اعرف على فكره يعني
مش لان انا متقاعس انا فعلا بشق الانفس
وما خليتش ورايا حاجه انما ما فيش شفافيه
عارف ما فيش شفيه فانت عندك كل الكلمه
اللي بتسمعيه كلمه ما يسمى رئيس الشركه
ا شركه ا العاصمه الادرج في في كيان
بالمعنى دو شركه العاصمه بيطلع علينا رئيس
شركه يقول حاجات من عندياته هو لكن الراي
العام وانا جزء من الراي العام بس انا
اكتر شويه لان را الاولا مشتغل بالسياسه
ثانيا بالاقتصاد فلازم اعرف الكلام دول
يعني حفيت ولم استطع لان بقول لك رقم طب
قو لي يعني المكونات وبعدين في نهايه يقول
لك لا لا ما تقلقش بقى اصل الموضوع ده كله
ماكلف ميزانيه الدوله حاجه طبعا يعني ده
كلام يعني يحتاج لمناقشه لانه
اولا المشروع اقيم على جزء من التراب
الوطني المصري صح اه وكل اضراب الوطن
المصري في التحليل الاخير هو ملك الشعب
المصري وليس ملك الحكومه دي مساله يعني في
الاول كده اذا كنت خدت ا الارض اقوللك
احنا خدنا الارض طورناها وبعنا وجبنا عائد
وحققنا مكسب عفوا انت هنا بتتكلم على
مفهوم الدوله ان الدوله هي عباره عن ايه
شعب يعيش على ارض ويختار حكومته هو ده
المفهوم وليست دوله بالمشروع
بالمفهوم السائد حاليا ما تقرا الوثيقه
بتاعه اتجاهات الريه يقوللك الدوله تنوي
الدوله وهو كل بيقصد حكومه اه فعايز اقول
انه غير صحيح هذا المشروع في راي انا ما
كان يجب ان يكون ما كان يجب ان يكون
اطلاقا وكتبت اك في
احداها خطيبه المسول كان ده اهدار المال
العام قبل ما نتورط دلوقتي خلاص تورطنا في
طيب يبقى اذا حضرتك بتتكلم في اطار برض
علشان الخط لا يتوه مني على الاقل يعني
انه حضرتك بتقول بديلا عن التعويم نقلل
الطلب على الدولار واذا طلل واذا قل الطلب
على الدولار فبد انه مش هنحتاج للتعويم
لان الدولار هيكون قليل مش الفرق بقى اللي
بنتكلم عليه ده بين السوق الرسمي يتقلص
تقلص وازاي نقلل الطلب على على الدولار
بان احنا نقلل الواردات ونقلل الواردات
باللجوء الى منظمه التجاره العالميه وفقا
للماده 18 ماده ب الفقره ب الفقره ب اثنين
انه نقلل الطلب العام يعني نتقف الطلب
الكلي الطلب الكلي وبالتالي التقشف ده
معناه ان الحكومه تنفق اقل ان تعيد النظر
في المشروعات انه الشعب نفسه يعيد النظر
في ثقافه الاستهلاك بلا حدود ط لا انا قلت
عفوا الكلام عشان برض النقطه دي شديده
الاهميه انه احنا محتاجين نعلن اقتصاد حرب
اه الموضوع ليس اقل اقل من ذلك بهذه
الخطوره وبالتالي نعل اقتصا بكل ما يترتب
على ذلك بالنسبه لسوء التصرف مثلا
المحتكرين والكلام ما تقدرش تتعامل معاهم
بالادوات العاديه قانون طلع سنه 45 مثلا
وتطبق غرامات او جزاءات تافهه جدا لا لازم
في ضبط وربط انما في النهايه نقطه احنا
عايزين يا جماعه نعيش في حدود الموارد
بتاعتنا بكرامه
وبكفاءة نقطه عايز اقول هنا بقى بتدخل في
عش دوبير لبين السياسه النقديه والسياسه
الماليه انت عندك عجز كبير في الموازنه
العامه للدوله وهذا العجز بيتمي الحكومه
ب طرح اذون خزانه وسندات خزانه الحكومه
بتستلف عشان تعرف تص مزبوط جزء منها
بيشتريه الخوجات ها اللي هو الاموال
الساخنه اللي بتيجي دي وعملت لنا مشاكل
الجزء الثاني اللي بيشتريه الافراد خلي
بالك بقى ل خط
محفظه الاقراض بتاعه الجهاز المصرفي تجد
ان في المتواصل 70% من القروض من الودائع
بتاعه عفوا 70% من
ودائع الافراد في البنوك في الجهاز
المصرفي المصري بوجه لشراء ادوات الدين
طبعا طب معنى الكلام ده لو حضرتك عاييز
تروح تاخد قرض عشان ت وسع مصنع قائم او
تاج صعوبه تاج صعوبه ليه لانه بالنسبه
للبنك ده بياخد عائد جبار جدا ومضمون ما
فيش اي مشكله ولا
خطوره فماش في السكه دي الموضوع محتاج
وقفه شديده جدا عشان اقدر اخلق الليح
بنسميه حيز مالي في المجتمع يحرك النشاط
الا النشاط الاقتصادي وطبعا الدكتور جوده
بيشير مره ثانيه الى فكره انه ما دام يعني
المجتمع او الاقتصاد ماشي على ثلاث اسس
اللي هو الشركات وبكل انواعها والافراد خط
الاعمال والخطاء العائلي والحكومه ا
والحكومه الافراد بيدخلوا شويه مش كتير
والقطاع الاعمال بيخر شويه مش كتير لكن
حتى اللي بيدخ ده بيجي الطرف الثالث اللي
هو الحكومه ايو بتقترب ما يدخره الافراد
وما يدخره قطاع الاعمال لان دايما عندها
فجوه بين ايراداتها ومصروفاتها صيح فاذا
اقترضت ما
ادخرته القطاع العائلي و قطاع الاعمال
النتيجه انه كل يعني دي اللي هي بتتحط في
البنك النتيجه ان المستثمر لو حب يروح
هيجدد المتبقي من هذه المدخرات محدود جدا
وبسعر مرتفع لا يشجع على اقتراض صح هل في
حلول اخرى اه في طبعا ما تقدرش تسيب بقى
ساحه سعر الصرف زي ما هي كده وكان شء لم
يكن ليه لانه المشكله فين بقى ا مشكله سعر
الصرف ناتجه عن نظام الصرف الصرف اه مساله
مهمه نظام الصرف هو الطريقه التي يتحدد
بها سعر الايه الصرف احنا حاليا نظامنا
ايه نظامنا رابطين الجنيه بتاعنا بالدولار
الامريكي وبناخد قرار مثلا دلوقتي بزين
ناخد قرار نرفع السعر الرسمي ده بتاع
الدولار من حوالي 31 جنيه نخفض مش هنرفع
يعني لا انا بالنسبه للدولار هو تخفيض
الجنيه خلاص ا او اخفض الجنيه اه طيب
وبعدين وبعد كده كله هيرتفع الدولار
واليورو
والريال وكله يعني والدرهم وكل حاجه انما
انما عندك مشكله كبيره جدا اللي هي اساسا
في علاقه عملتك بباقي عملات العالم بخلاف
الدولار بمعنى ان ممكن جدا معطيات
العلاقات اذا لو خدنا الاتحاد الاوروبي
كمثال عميه اليورو ك معروف والولايات
المتحده عميه الدولار ممكن الولايات
المتحده المتحده تحقق فائض في مواجهه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي قيمه الدولار
ترتفع اه في مواجهه اليورو صح اه طبقى
النظام الحالي مباشره قيمه الجنيه المصري
ترتفع في مواجهه اليورو واذا ارت رغم انه
عندنا عجز بس يعني هو حضرتك قلت الفكره دي
قبل كده بس ممكن ده يبقى عامل لكن يعني
انا يعني على حدود فهم المتواضع انه مش
عامل مؤثر قوي
ليه لانه فروق ما بين الدولار واليورو
والاسترليني و كلها فروق بتطلع وتنزل في
حدود بسيطه يعني مش فاذا انا اذا الدولار
ارتفع قدام اليورو هيكون 2% 3% وبعدين
بترجع تاني وانا في كل الاحوال عندي عجز
اجاه كل هذه الكتل الاقتصاديه اظبط ولكن
اللي انا عايز اقوله
انه ما هكذا ما هكذا يدار سوق الصرف سوق
الصرف يحتاج
الى تطبيق نظام صرف محترم اه اللي هو ربط
الجنيه با قلنا الكلام ده و في المؤتمر
الاقتصادي اثير في اكتوبر سنه 22 تمام
وبتاع القائم في سبب تفتكر حضرتك على
لتجاهل الفكره دي والله انا ما مش فاهم
ليه يعني
اصلا القائم باعمال محافظ البنك اللي هو
الاستاذ حسن قال لك احنا فعلا ه نطلع
مؤشر لعلاقه بنا في كليه الاقتصاد نعمل
اتصالات بنك يا جماعه احنا مستعدين نساعد
في العمليه دي علميا اه عشان نطلع صيغه
انما اذا كان صعب من ناحيه ناحيه البحث
والجداره الفنيه جهاز التعبير خد وحده
حقوق السحب الخاص وربط الجنيه بتاعك بوحده
اللي هو عمله اللي هو عمله اللي هي العمله
اللي بتعا بقى النقد الوحده الحسابيه اللي
هي مبنيه على سال عملات خ ساله عملات طيب
هذا مقترح اخر ماذا ايه دهاني عمل يا
دكتور
ا ده ده مقترح انك انت تتغير نظام الصرف
مرتبطا بكل هذا بقى لا يمكن الثقب الكبير
اللي بيسمى حركه رؤوس الاموال
الساخنه تعمل فيه حاجه انا ما بقولش تقفله
بالكامل لو تذكر من فتره قصيره جدا في
مارس من سنه تقريبا طلع 20 مليار دولار
باعتراف الحكومه هل تاذ لي اوضح ايه هي
رؤوس الاموال الاموال الساخنه عشان حض
تكمل الاموال الساخنه وبعال الدكتور يصحح
لي ايه الفكره ان في مستثمرين المستثمرين
دول عاده بتمثل صناديق استثمار او بنوك
عنده مدخرات ناس كتيره
قوي وليكن مثلا بالدولار بنك امريكي البنك
الامريكي ده عاوز يستثمر ويربح بدون بذل
جهد فايه اللي بيحصل هو بياخد بيقت هو
نفسه دولار مثلا 100 مليون دولار من
امريكا بسعر سي مثلا لما كانت 2% ولا ب 1%
ويجي هنا يحولها لمصر يقرض الحكومه
المصريه او اي الحكومه التركيه او
الباكستانيه وياخد فايده زي مثلا 15% ولا
12% ويطلع تاني بالدولار بتاعه يعني
العمله المحليه حولها الى الدولار فيجد
انه بدل اقترض ب 2% لكنه رابح حوالي 4%
بالدولار حاجه زي كده مع الدكتور مش كده
صح هو زي هي الاموال الساخنه الاموال
الساخنه ديت بتذهب وتاتي بحثا عن الربح
الس
واذا شعروا باي خطر والخطر بيتمثل في
احتمال عدم السداد بيخرج فورا صح الكلام
اه اتفضل يا هذه الاموال حينما تدخل تخلق
ضغوطا اقتصاديه وحينما تخرج تخلق ضغوطا
اقتصاديه وبالتالي ما هي الضغوط التي تخلط
انه لما وهو
داخل عايز يبيع لك دولارات ويحوله لجنيهات
مش كده ولا ايه ف بيزود الطلب على الجنيه
فترتفع قيمه الايه الجنيه عظيم اه ترتفع
بغير منطق يعني ايوه بمنطق السوق عظيم وهو
خارج ب ط لما ترتفع قيمه الجنيه يحصل ايه
تنافسيته في مجال الانتاج هتقل هتقل تمام
مظبوط وهو خارج بيعمل العمليه العكسيه
فتنخفض قيمه
الجنيه فده ده الموضوع يعني بالنسبه لحركه
الاقتصاد لا يجوز ان يحدث لس و انت لا
تستطيع ان تتنبا متى ستدخل هذه الاموال
الصخر بتتم ده بشكل فجائي عظيم طبعا واحد
اثنين بتتم بمبالغ زي ما شفنا 20 مليار في
ارقام ضخمه ها يعني تحدث زلزله في الوضع
المالي والاقتصادي في في البلد نمره ثلاثه
انه ليس له اي مردود في الواقع اللهم الا
سد ما تسميه الحكومه الفج الدولاريه جيلي
الكلام ده بسد الفجوه وداريه هو في سؤالين
وارجو ان حضرتك يعني يعني ممكن نختم بيه
دي ونكمل في حلقه اخرى اذا ما كانش في نقد
الجوهريه تمام المقترح حضرتك خلاصته انه
يجب انه انا اقلل الطلب على الدولار
وهعمله بعده طرق الذهاب الى منظمه التجاره
خفض الانفاق الكلي التقشف الى اخره وطبعا
مواجهه الاموال الساخنه ديت اللي الحكومه
بتتطلع اليها بشده علشان السؤال هنا ان ده
اجراء جيد لو الحكومه يعني ده مقترح وجيه
جدا لكن لو الحكومه حابت تعمله ده هيتطلب
شهور طويله هل خلال الشهور الطويله دي
اللي هو ايه انه يحط قيود لا انه يحاول
يقلل انه دلوقتي يضع قيود على الواردات
ويجهز ملفه ويطلع على منظمه التجاره لو هي
تبنت هذا يعني اي وانه يقلل التقشف عاوز
تغييرات جوهريه نفترض ان الحكومه مشيت
فيها طبعا ده افتراض انا اعتقد ان هو بعيد
عن التفكير الستيشن يعني لكن نفترض ده
ممكن يستمر يحتاج سنتين ثلاثه مين وايل
برضو لا للتعويم اه ليه بقى لا اولا مش مش
محتاجين سنتين لاثه كويس تقدير انا الامور
محتاج شهور اه كويس كده قد تكون ست سب سنه
مثلا ممكن انما لما انت بتبدا عمليه زي
دي بتبدا من خط اساس مختلف انت خلاص داخل
في مفاوضات
يعني انت بتعمل الكلام ده ولكن في نفس
الوقت انا طرحت عندك التزامات حاله لازم
تواجهها تمام انا من منطلق ان انا يعني
انا مدين حسن النيه اه وتاريخي باشه عمري
ما مطلت ولا تلكات كمصر يعني ايوه انما
حاليا انا بواجه بضغوط صدمه اقتصاديه
شديده جدا مش شديده فقط وبالتالي هذا بيقل
من قدرتي على الاستمرار في الوفاء
بالتزاماته اللي انا حريص على الوفاء بها
في معادها وبناء عليه انا مش معطل ولا
بتنصر من الديون انا مطلب اعاده النظر في
اه الذهاب الى نادي باريس مظبوط مظبوط ده
يبقى احنا كده عندنا حل طويل الامد وحل
قصير الامد الحل القصير الامد لان انا في
عشرات المليارات واجبه السداد على مصر
خلال 2024 و2
حضرتك بتقتل الذهاب الى نادي باريس لاعاده
جدوله الديون واحد اثنين على مدى ابعد او
بالتوازي معاه ان نقوم باجراءات خفض
الطلب على الواردات وخفض الطلب حتى كمان
في الداخل بالقش وبالمناسبه انا قدمت في
مناسبات كثير ربما نتكلم عن الموضوع ده
بحقه وقدمت برنامج بديل من ع نقاط على
كيفيه التعامل مع هذا مع هذا الوضع ببراح
بس لما تاخذ اجراءات حل بالشكل اللي انا
قلت عليه وانا باكد مره ثانيه لمن يروجون
للتعويم ان التعويم ليس هو الحل احنا
جربناه ودول اخرى جربته مره بعد مره بعد
مره واخرهم في 2016 لو تذكروا وخدنا 12
مليار مش لاثه ولا اربعه ولا خمسه زي زي
حاليا وانتهى الامر انه انا عندي ديون
حاله وضغطه وعايز يعني اواجه التزامات
فالجا للتعويض شكرا جزيلا مع دكتور اهلا
بك ض